[Musique]
déjà traversé les siècles laissant
derrière elle un voile de mystère et de
crainte superstitieuse
ces guerriers de l'invisible viennent du
japon féodal employés par les seigneurs
aux côtés des samouraïs
il était occupé tels des espions à des
tâches le plus souvent secrètes en
mission ils utilisaient la ruse et les
arts martiaux
de plus il savait parfaitement se servir
de toutes les armes blanches au japon
l'enseignement de ninjutsu l'art
guerriers des ninjas appartient encore à
un nombre restreint d'initiés
c'est pourquoi en france il ya seulement
six mois que sylvain gatard issus de
l'école toga tueur et enseigne le
ninjutsu anarchy aujourd'hui allie
technique de combat et méditation les
techniques guerrières comme vous avez pu
constater son et techniques qu'on
appelle t tout guerrière rien à voir
avec le dossier technique meurtrière
donc il n'est pas question de revenir
comme avant
si les techniques sont à changer bon il
est plus question de faire de
l'espionnage mon respect âge c'est un
art martial donc au fur et à mesure car
atik s'intensifie la partie devient de
plus en plus dur et bien pour accéder à
ce niveau de pratique on demande aux
gens d'avoir aussi un mental qui va avec
le niveau de plus en plus dures donc on
fait des à 16 ont fait énormément de
méditation les c'est une méditation qui
est particulière puisqu'elle est issue
de moines guerriers les yamabushi au
japon donc on demande aux gens qui
pratiquent le ninjutsu d'être aussi
résistant face à la douleur
résistant face à la douleur et surtout
avoir un état d'esprit particulier à nos
pointes à l'esprit renfermer sur soi du
combattant ou dureté le contraire une
ouverture de la foire pour ne pas
devenir des fous de ninjutsu mais aussi
et surtout pour se purifier faire le
plein d'énergie
les ninjas pratique méditation et à 16
parmi ces à 16 la marche sont les
braises ou plus couramment le passage
sous des cascades
ce jour là le thermomètre indiquait +2
quant à la température de l'eau elle
n'excédait pas les 7 degrés
[Applaudissements]
passer sous la casquette qu'est ce que
c'est un rappeur de mari sous une
cascade et bien ça rapporte d'une part
la santé il y avait un accident parce
occident si c'est bien fait
la cascade obligés de voter parce
qu'elle les autres et puis après
première fois est dur et puis on n'ose
pas ce que ce matin ça n'avait pas l'air
très facile c'était la première fois que
l'occasion faisait en hiver c'est tout à
fait différent si j'enseigne documents
ou
de la glace autour de soi tu crois pas
qu'il faut être un peu fou
[Musique]
je crois que pour ça je n'y suis pas un
fou mais ça allait bien et si on ne met
pas comment ça on peut devenir par la
suite
non non c'est une blague mais je crois
que c'est ce sur quoi il faut à
caractère volontaire et vouloir y croire
en ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]